moving on
our main story tonight concerns hair
specifically black hair
the subject that gave us the single
greatest real housewives entrance of
all time when kenya moore crashed marlo
hampton's wig launch with a marching
band to promote her own line of hair
products
and porsha williams reacted like this
even if i did agree with kenya and the
fact that people's edges matter
they don't matter today you are
wrong this is absolutely insane
okay so today i don't agree but tomorrow
yes my edges matter and i'll be using
the product
you know what as per usual porsche is
right about a number of things there
kenya is wrong
edges do matter and i like porsche will
also be using the product tomorrow
monday is my wash day and look i realize
i'm not the ideal person to talk about
black hair i look like i still go to an
old timey barber named valentino and ask
for
the tidy liza minelli and i also know
that the danger is
when a white guy on tv starts
confidently talking about black hair
even with the best of intentions
it can end something like this i didn't
want the little
tea light to overheat and then all of a
sudden we've got breaking news here at
the channel i told you the sprinkler
system's come on i'm done for the day
yeah there you go that is sitting up
here looking like a mop
yeah you don't want sprinkler system and
a beautiful weave because they do not go
oh wow you're beautiful
you said it was a weaver it's not oh
wow that is the exact right reaction to
announcing your black co-workers hair is
a weave live on air getting up from your
desk and just running away
running forever running until your life
fades behind you and your feet touch the
ocean
now you should know those two co-workers
seem to have gotten over that incident
putting out a video titled
blaine and layla discuss hair weave a
rebuttal where blaine says he's learned
the difference between quick weaves lace
fronts and sew-ins
because of their friendship but the fact
is on the whole
white people don't really understand a
lot about black hair and by the way if
your first reaction to that was hey
not all white people maybe look inside
yourself and figure out why
that is your response to things but
importantly that lack of understanding
and lack of interest in
understanding can have real consequences
from the personal
to the professional as you probably know
either from experience or from seeing
stories like this
chastity jones was tangled in a nearly
10-year legal battle after she says an
employer took back a job offer at an
alabama call center
because she refused to cut her hair she
said are those
dreadlocks in your hair and i
just looked at her and i was like these
and she said yes i said yes they are
she said well
we can accept that here can you imagine
turning someone away who wants to work
at a call center
the university's most thankless job a
place where you answer the phone and
immediately there's an angry woman
screaming at you because
some of the broccolini in her hello
fresh kits didn't smell right and now
she wants to speak to mr fresh
if you have someone who wants to do that
job let them
what's on their head has nothing to do
with it they could show up to work in a
wig made of living ferrets
and they deserve not only that position
but double whatever you're paying them
the point is black hair and hairstyles
are frequently yet another pretext for
discrimination so tonight
let's talk about it and let's start by
understanding why black
hair is so important for centuries black
people in africa
innovated ways to protect and prolong
the health of their hair and that
practice
has continued and evolved into beautiful
and distinct
hairstyles with a deep connection to
culture and heritage and for as long
as that has happened white people have
been unable to handle it
one of the first things slave traders
would do was shave the heads of enslaved
people which erased their cultural
identity
and black hair has historically been
described in dehumanizing fashion
with racial typologist charles hamilton
smith describing his hierarchy of three
main types of people
the bearded caucasian type the beardless
mongolic type and the
woolly head tropical type and the only
time
wooly head tropical is an acceptable
term to use is if you're talking about
madagascar's
woolly lemur a tropical little sweetie
who always looks like he just
accidentally replied all
other than that it's off limits now
by the late 19th century beauty
companies were advertising products like
skin lighteners and hair straighteners
reinforcing the idea that black hair was
dirty and unkempt
and the closer your appearance was to
whiteness the better like in this ad
from 1900
from magnetic comb that promised to
destroy the hair germs
on your head and take you from a curly
head black person
to a straight haired white one and the
desire to make black hair smoother and
straighter
was so strong just listen to the sheer
delight
this british newsreel takes in showing
you the process
combs come into play kept constantly
heated they are passed through each
section of the hair until all trace of
kinkiness disappears
it's not all plain sailing naturally and
it's not quite a permanent permanent if
you follow me
if the hair gets really wet or steamed
up it unstraightens itself and
back come the kinks oh no hearing that
beauty standard reinforced in that
particular voice
is definitely a sign that something has
gone terribly wrong
and i know for some viewers passing a
hot metal comb through the hair to
straighten it might look like a curio
from the distant past but i
guarantee some of you were just
transported back
to being eight years old sitting on a
high stall in the kitchen at six am on
school picture day
holding your ears down while your mom or
grandma gets the hot comb uncomfortably
close to your scalp
for some the smell of burning hair is a
sign that something's wrong but for
others
it brings back memories by the 1960s and
70s though the embrace of black hair's
natural texture and culturally
significant styles
had become a radical act of
self-acceptance and political power
who taught you to hate the texture of
your hair
who taught you to heat the color of your
skin to such extent that you bleach
to get like the white man are white
people
the answer is white people that question
answers itself just like the answer to
the questions
who lets their dogs kiss them in the
mouth who wants to pick apples for fun
and
who's coming to dinner on einergarten
show the answer is
white people but despite the natural
hair movement
white people's discomfort and ignorance
around black hair has very much remained
one study found black women were 80
percent more likely to agree with the
statement
i have to change my hair from its
natural state to fit in at the office
and another found that black women with
natural hair styles will perceive to be
less professional
less competent and less likely to be
recommended for a job interview the
point is
the way your hair is perceived and
therefore the way
you are perceived can manifest in all
sorts of ways
i know the anxiety that people have
after getting their hair done
then like okay what's gonna happen when
i go to work are they gonna say anything
you know it's a big thing in the
workplace a lot of people don't want to
draw attention to themselves but they
try to do the norm
a lot of the time i would always get
people just like saying how like soft my
hair is and everything and like wanting
to touch it that's like always a big
pain
and like adults doing that too i'm like
wrong with them i can't touch it
you know you don't touch no black women
here no you already know that i feel
like
you're in a zoo look you obviously
shouldn't be made to feel like you're in
a zoo
ever for any reason also and this is
clearly not the point but if you are
touching animals at the zoo
you're doing the zoo wrong don't be
stressing out the otters by
shouting unwanted questions and trying
to sneak your hands into the cages to
cop a field
yes the bald eagles feathers are late
but don't shout yes queen and try to pet
her
unlike your co-workers the eagle will
snap your fingers off
and you will have it coming
unfortunately though
white people's biases and ignorance are
often just laying in wait
for the right moment to strike jonathan
sutherland is a penn state football
captain and a dean's list student but
what people are talking about tonight
is his hair that's thanks to this letter
the author is a proclaimed alumnus from
decades ago
named david peterson he called
sutherland's hair
awful stating his locks are disgusting
and are certainly not attractive
he also writes we would welcome the
reappearance of dress codes for athletes
everything about that is upsetting from
the racist attitude to the
hurtful language to the fact that he
chose to express moral outrage over
something in college football but it's
not that the
ncaa makes millions of student athletes
instead it's
i can see your hair outside your helmet
now that man later explained that he
only wrote the letter because i was just
disgruntled about
some of the hairdos that we're seeing
you think of penn state as a bunch of
clean-cut guys
and you think of penn state as is just
not a sentence that ends well under any
circumstance especially when you realize
that man actually got a degree from penn
state in 1966
the same year as jerry sandusky who
somehow
despite his short hair turned out to be
a heinous sex criminal
i know it sounds ridiculous but it's
almost like the haircut
doesn't matter and it starts way
before college
you may remember the terrible case of
high school wrestler andrew johnson who
was basically forced to cut his locks
off
or forfeit an important wrestling match
by a referee that case
made national news but there are
hundreds of others that don't
from the school in kentucky that once
banned and i quote dreadlocks and
corn rolls two twin sisters in
massachusetts that received
hours of detention because of their
braided hair to this daycare in suburban
chicago
mom may like the smell but according to
this note tiona norris posted on her
facebook page
amaya's teacher didn't like it basically
saying
your child stinks don't put the coconut
oil in her hair
the kids were teasing her norris says
amaya was the only black child in her
preschool class at the racquetian
learning center in elmhurst i was just
hurt from my child
especially after noor says she met with
a teacher and school administrator
and learned the children in the class
never complained
it was just a teacher who didn't like
the smell we called the school and left
several messages we visited and got this
hi i'm dorothy tucker from channel 2
goodbye
wow that feels like a perfectly staged
five-second play encapsulating the
history of race relations in america
a black person trying to discuss racial
inequality with a white person then
immediately says
goodbye so black people from an early
age are often told that their hair is
unattractive and needs to be corrected
and that is already just
a lot before you even start getting into
all the ways that society makes it
difficult
to navigate the world because of your
hair even just
buying hair products can be an
unnecessary challenge with black hair
products
routinely locked in a case where someone
has to come with a key to get it for you
or maybe even
walk it to the register in the same
aisle where products for white people
that cost just as much or more
are simply sitting out on the shelves
and the explanation for this
is never great so i went and found the
manager
and i said i'm waiting for the key for
shampoo
and conditioner i said but let me ask
you
why are the black hair products locked
up and not the white hair
products he said um um and another
associate said
well people have been stealing yeah now
that walmart
claims that it was based on data of
theft in the store but
when a town council member asked to see
that data the store instructed her to
call
1 800 walmart and just out of interest
on a touch tone phone which button do
you press to hear the data used
to justify locking up four dollar eco
styler gel is that like number seven
or do you have to ask for an associate
first so
it is already hard enough to get
products to do your hair
at home but finding a qualified stylist
can be
even harder the cosmetology industry
mostly revolves around and trains four
caring for straight non-textured hair so
there is no guarantee
that a stylist in your area can work
with black hair
just watch one tick tocker call 23
salons in their hometown and get nothing
but responses like these
i was wondering if you guys worked with
african-american hair
specifically for c-type uh we do not
none of the girls do
here no we don't really have a lot of
experience
so i would say that you're probably
better to keep
looking around i was wondering if you
guys were able to work with
african-american hair
specifically for c-type oh hold on just
a moment
let me ask is
[Music]
yeah that's not great but i do love that
that receptionist is asking the entire
staff like she just got called as a
phone a friend on who wants to be a
millionaire
hey donna it's the 25 000 question can
you do a silk press and bump those ends
final answer she can't and this
isn't just a problem in salons even in
hollywood stylists who are both familiar
with black hair
and who are in the stylist union are
rare and actors
definitely know when their production
has failed to hire one
i was on this show they made me a series
regular i was hella pumped
walked in a hair makeup trailer first
time oh i'm about to like get paid
let me see
homegirl this white lady she tapped my
head
yep not lying she tapped it sprayed some
water
didn't brush didn't calm and left and i
was like
oh wild now i actually recommend going
back and watching each actor in that
clip as he tells that story because you
really get the sense
that every one of them identifies with
what he's saying there
and it's not ideal that for a lot of
hairstylists their strategy to deal with
black clients
is the same that you would use to get
your cat off the kitchen counter
give them a little spritz and they give
them a pat on the head so they know
you're not mad
and when you consider all of the
obstacles to get placed in the path of
black people
it's understandably pretty hard to take
when white people wear the exact same
hairstyles that they get judgment for
from bo derek famously wearing braids in
the movie 10 to adele and miley cyrus
trying on black hairstyles for fun to
this con de garcon fashion show at which
the models wore
lace front cornrow wigs which were awful
in every possible way i mean just look
at that thing
there is enough room between each braid
to land a plane there
and you don't even have to look closely
to see the model's dark hair through the
lace come on
you put a wick cap on first then you put
the wig on you grab your gotta be spray
or wig glue you melt that lace and you
lay those edges down so well they fall
asleep
there are only two situations where the
appalling level of wig application is
acceptable either
you're in the middle of hosting an
episode of snl or you're posing as a
british nanny to stay close to your
children after your divorce
that is it and the thing is
white people appropriating black
hairstyles isn't just infuriating
it can directly make it harder for black
people to fight discrimination
concerning their hair
there was a court case in 1981 a
discrimination suit
filed by a black woman named renee
rogers she'd work for american airlines
and she wore her hair in cornrows her
legal argument was that her
hairstyle was a part of her cultural
heritage the judge
ruled against her in federal court
because he said she got her
hair done soon after the movie 10 came
out and therefore
there was no legal basis for saying it
was cultural heritage because she was
doing something that essentially was
imitating how bo derek styled her hair
yeah it's true among the reasons he
dismissed her case the judge suggested
that a black person
wearing a traditionally black hairstyle
was just copying a white celebrity who
stole it
from black people which is just
ridiculous
hairstyles have cultural roots they
don't just come
out of nowhere to sweep the nation with
the sole exception of course of
the rachel which wasn't appropriated
from any culture it simply sprang forth
fully formed from the concept known as
the 90s and i wish i could say that that
is a thing of the past but you
know it isn't chastity jones the woman
you saw earlier
spent years appealing her case only to
lose in part
because judges interpreted civil rights
law to protect against discrimination
based only on
immutable or unchangeable
characteristics associated with race
like skin color so for decades courts
have found that
hairstyles even though they are deeply
tied to racial identity
are not covered and all of that means
that a younger generation
can still end up having to deal with
this nineteen-year-old destiny
tompkins has worked at this banana
republic store at the
westchester mall in white plains for
just about a month she was called into a
meeting with her
manager on wednesday caught completely
off guard
by what happened next he was like yeah
so the district manager came in she
pointed out something about your hair
and i'm like okay so what's wrong with
my hair he said it's a little too urban
and unkempt for our look
and for our image we were just wondering
like if you could just take them out
okay putting aside the use of the word
urban there a level of tone deafness on
par with naming your store
banana republic just take them out
those are words from someone who has
zero idea
of what it took to put them in in the
first place that is coming from a man
who i'm guessing
has never spent seven hours in a salon
chair with an ipad full of movies and a
backpack full of stacks
now you should know the store called
that unacceptable
and the manager was fired but the
problem is since professionalism gets
defined by white standards and
expectations
black hair is more likely to crash into
those expectations so
what can we do well for some of the
smaller issues you've seen tonight there
have been changes
some chain stores including walmart have
announced that they will
no longer be locking up black hair
products which feels like
the least that they can do but it is a
start a bigger change
would be to pass laws like crown acts or
creating a respectful and open world for
natural hair
versions have already become law in
these 11 states and while the
language varies generally they expand
the definition of race and
anti-discrimination
laws to include traits historically
associated with race
like protective hairstyles such as
braids locks and twists
unfortunately crown acts bills have
repeatedly met with republican
opposition
in utah in one recent zoom hearing on
their bill state senator darren owens
who voted against it
made a point of first addressing the
bill's advocates like this
let me make a comment you people are
beautiful
i and i don't normally do this but i'm
going to show you
in a i was in the store the other day
and
i don't think you won't be able to see
this picture but this
gentleman in front of me with my black
man had two young children and they were
just
having fun around up and down the island
and i don't normally take pictures of
children but they were
adorable to black children because
they're just the cutest kids in the
world one has
cornrows and one of them dreadlocks i
wish you could see them
what are you doing you exceptionally
weird man
just to recap he started off there by
telling a group of black women
you people are beautiful then proceeded
to say i don't normally take pictures of
children
but a perfectly acceptable sentence
until the butt part
then launched into a story about how he
keeps photos of strangers children on
his phone all of which
evokes a response perhaps best summed up
by this expression which i'd argue
is an absolute master class in how to
say the
using only your eyebrows and if you are
wondering
how he got from that to voting against
the bill
his argument was that he felt existing
laws were sufficient and that
it almost looks like we're trying to do
something that doesn't exist
but this discrimination isn't something
that doesn't exist
it's something that doesn't exist for
white men who've never had to think
about it before
the consequences of hair based
discrimination are very
real just listen to connecticut state
senator gary winfield
make the case for his state's crown act
in the run-up to it passing into law
by talking about his three-year-old
daughter right now she
runs through life with all of the energy
that she has with all of the beauty that
she has
with her hair natural
that's who she is it's not just what
sits on top of her head it is who
she is but i want her to be able to
participate in this world fully
and so even if she runs through this
world with her natural hair there will
be a discussion about what it is to run
through this world with her naturally
and what she will have to learn whether
she makes the choice to run through this
world
with her natural hair or not
is that a part of her
is not acceptable that's awful
it's infuriating that black children
have to add hair discrimination
to the long list of things that they're
already forced to think about like the
threat of police violence the danger of
harassment by racist white people and of
course
the very real risk of getting
photographed by utah state senator
darren owens
in a checkout line that man's
daughter
and all black people should clearly be
able to make choices about their hair
based on what they feel like doing with
it
rather than will this get me harassed or
fired if you want to have natural hair
great you want to straighten your hair
great whatever you like
the point is black hair shouldn't be
viewed corralled or judged by white
people's comfort
because it doesn't belong to white
people it doesn't affect white people
and white people
really don't need to have an opinion on
it and our laws should reflect that
and i know that there may be limits to
what crown acts can accomplish
even if one passes at the federal level
there could be cases where a white judge
is asked to decide whether a specific
hairstyle is associated with race and
completely it up but they are a
start
and look if you're not a black person
it's probably easy to hear these stories
and think
well it's just hair but the thing is
it's not it's not at all black people
aren't getting hired or are getting
fired black students are being teased
taunted and removed from school
all because of their hair and crown acts
laws
could make a real difference there and
while social stigma and
unrealistic beauty standards aren't
going to go away overnight there are a
few things
that white viewers in particular might
want to keep in mind going forward and
to that end
if you are one there's a message that
you should probably hear
hi white people i'm uzo aduba i'm craig
robinson
hi white people i'm leslie jones what's
up black people
brothers and sisters you good your mama
good
all right listen i gotta talk to these
white people for a second
i'll see you at the meet all right look
white people
i know you have lots of questions like
maybe
too many questions like how often do you
have to wash black hair
what is the silk press what does a
do-rag
do well the good news is we are about to
fill you in
we're about to give you the answer to
all your questions about black hair
you ready for it you ready for it you
ready for it okay here it is
google it google it
google it google it i mean it
doesn't have to be google
it can be bing youtube wikipedia
i don't give a
the information is out there and once
you get the information you can
appreciate
all the beauty and hard work it takes to
keeping my hair laid and looking good
okay and if you're not interested in
googling it there is another option
off leave us the alone
off it's always an option and look white
people don't tell me you can't figure
this out on your own you figured out
settlers of catan you figured out
sourdough bread last year i think you
can google the word wii
you can learn what the a box braid
is
okay i think that just about
covers it basically just
google it don't touch it and there's one
more thing don't spray my hair with
water and tap my head
i'm not a cat bye goddamn white people
you